so
i don't know if you know sort of the
more mathematical discipline of game
theory
there's something called mechanism
design so game theory is this
field where you model some kind of
interaction between human beings
you can model grappling that way you can
uh
model nuclear conflict between nations
that way and
uh you set up a set of rules and
incentives
and then use math to predict
uh what is the likely outcome depending
over time
based on the interaction given those
rules mechanism design
is the design of games
so like the design of systems that
are likely to lead to a certain outcome
and so what you're suggesting is you
want to
create you want to discover systems
whose decision tree all the possible
things that could happen
feel like there's choice being made but
ultimately one of the parties doesn't
have
any choice in what the actual final
outcome is
uh you're making them feel like they're
playing a game too so it's not like
you don't feel trapped it's kind of like
well the best traps
i don't you don't look very threatening
so i'm like oh i'll walk over there
i guess wouldn't that i guess that's
kind of an interesting thing if a lion
when does a lion roar it's an
interesting thing when you watch like
lions hunting
don't roar when they hunt they want to
when they want to move you back if they
do stuff like that when they actually
want to come and get you they're pretty
slinky it's like water covered it's like
furry water yeah
and and i guess like when you keep that
in mind
um it's funny how like a frosted hobby
actually
a brilliant guy like one of my mma
coaches and head coach at tristar
um he brought this up one time i thought
it was a really salient point he said
let's say we have a million
person bracket impossibly huge like
frank dukes winning the kumite level
huge bracket
he claimed to knock out like 250
consecutive people and you're like that
is
all of hong kong was in that thing and
everyone kept their mouth shut
but anyway that's pretty cool but uh
it's a comeback a little improbable
pretty cool um so let's say for instance
like there's no cheating going on
no cheating going on and we're flipping
coins right someone is going to have an
unbroken string of victory through that
bracket
which is pretty insane how many how many
consecutive like toss-ups this person
won
and then at the end of it all imagine we
like aliens show up and we go hey they
want to flip a coin before they're not
earth
whether or not earth uh you know gets to
gets to continue they're like oh
i'll do it i'm good at this
that would be tempting as a person to to
do you're like well i'm a lucky guy
are you like are you sure maybe i mean
maybe effectively you are we could argue
that effectively you're incredibly lucky
but basically
is that an actual ability is it like a
perk in a video game or is that just
this thing that happened
so anyway uh how many times are someone
you could go through an entire career
you know particularly in a fights board
well let's say you get 15 knockouts in
15 toss-up scenarios because you see
that happening all the time in the fight
game a toss-up scenario it's not like
you're mounted on me and like and
that's not a toss-up scenario many many
many many many striking centers a lot of
grappling with but tons of striking
scenarios are
dead toss-ups and uh somebody wins by
knockout they win five times in a row
then they lose a couple times in a row
and we go what happened you're like what
do you mean what happened they were
always flipping the coin
and then they win five more and they go
ah back on track can you imagine that
you're flipping a coin on like heads
heads heads heads tails what
tails heads again oh man i'm back on it
i'm flipping good now
that's basically what's going on i think
the vast majority of the time
and then humanity's you know tendency to
see a sign in almost anything
you know it starts to present itself and
then we build a narrative in our mind to
convince ourselves that we're in some
sort of control when in reality i was in
a marginal situation at best
the whole time yeah without having much
control without having a deep
understanding of the system the same
story is told the stock market with many
of the human these distributed human
systems
we start telling narratives and start
seeing patterns without understanding
actually
the system that's generating these
patterns so if we can see the system
that's incredibly valuable but then you
go well what system is above all of the
systems i guess
maybe physics maybe some like game
theory explains these things but like i
guess what are the
what aspects of the system can i can i
put my hands on that i can touch and
understand
and what am i what am i missing what
what what's going on in the world all
around me to continue to
lean on on dune that i don't have uh
that i don't you know you talk to a
blind person about
about the world about sight and talk to
someone that doesn't have everyone
who's got coronavirus now so no one can
taste or smell like this is delicious
like
is it so anyway uh you know again
what what senses am i missing or what
understanding am i missing
that's preventing me from seeing the
dots connect
in the world all around me and i think
sometimes if we uh
oftentimes at least personally have
screwed this up a lot i'm so
nose deep in the in the trench of trying
to understand what i'm doing that i
can't take a step back and realize
you know that i'm in a forest not just
head-butting a tree
and i may be doing both maybe both two
things should be true at once
but uh so i would say when it comes to
strategy trying to understand that but
then also you go well
okay well how can that sounds cool but
how can you actually do that
and then i'd say that's a really good
question because if i imagine i say man
i should fight like stephen thompson i
should fight like wonder boy he's like
good idea go do that i'm like
ah i'm not thinking about the guy i
would fight like he'd even bag i made
off if i could
you know it seems to work so anyway uh
you go well what if i could develop what
if i could take my time developing
skills
so that when these strategies become
apparent that you are they are
executable to you
you actually have the ability to like
enter to again to be the person in the
arena to be the person required
whereas there's plenty of great ideas
like dunking a basketball is a fantastic
idea
alas for me unless there's a small
trampoline nearby i'm not the guy
but that doesn't make it any less good
of an idea i just don't i haven't
developed the ability
or or i lack the ability so anyway i
think a lot of times at least when i
watch people in fighting i'll use an
example
um we're so can we're so concerned with
trying to win early on
rather than develop skills that i'm
going like well what's the best way to
fight with my current set of skills
and usually the the path forward is like
the barbarian route like the
you put on the one ring take the damage
you need to take to hit that guy and
that was something i realized very early
on in my mma career was like i'm not
that good at striking at that time not a
world-class striker now but i'm
way better at striking than i'm giving
any credit for because it helps people
sleep at night i think
but um i'm serious but uh um yeah yeah
you're always introduced as like this
massive
like master grappler i'm like it's nice
of them to say that maybe i'm not that
good at grappling we haven't even seen
that and
but the funny thing is i'm like just
because if people almost go like well
lex like
see you're really good at this but you
gotta understand like we're equal man
like i'm good at this other thing
maybe you're really good at what you do
and i'm just mediocre what i do that's
also possible
so there's plenty of people that define
themselves as a striker that do that
just because that's for lack of other
options not because they're a really
good striker
like i'm a grappler i was a grappler as
a blue belt not really
so anyway i guess to come back uh if if
i'm constantly going how can i win with
what i've got right now i think
oftentimes i never take the time to
develop the skills that i want to
develop and i also never take the time
to develop the strategies that i want to
develop and that has actually been
one big blessing of uh fighting someone
frequently which has been really
frustrating as a result of injury
and time away and you know some of those
people being hesitant to get in the game
but uh it gives you so much time to to
be out of the trenches and focus on
developing
your abilities so that now it's almost
like developing money like you mentioned
the stock market that you can now put in
as you told me bitcoin was a great idea
five years ago and i had eight bucks
man if someone told me bitcoin was a
great idea five years ago and i had you
know 50k
oh my god i'd be sleeping in my bed of
money that i would then set on fire
later today just to do it
so all the due to all the injuries
you've been mining bitcoin all this time
and now you're a rich man well no
actually somebody told me i was trying
to mine for bitcoin
actually like in a cave and then i found
out recently that it's actually
mining is like a figure of speech not
like a literal thing that you do
but i mean in my defense english
language is difficult it is it really is
next time russian is more
uh is a ritual language you should learn
you should learn russian i'll help you
out i believe you thank you
you